we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p got a very
weird voicemail here is my question is
this an anti-trump voicemail or is this
a voicemail against those who are
anti-trump in other words is this person
on the left or on the right is this
person angry with me or are they angry
with trumpets let's see if we can figure
it out through all of the expletives i
mister pac-man what is up with all the
hate mongering on your [ __ ] Facebook
threads there this is ridiculous how can
you say this and not want to go say hey
y'all can pay like this it's ridiculous
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
you want to make fun of people like that
people just because they wants to care
boaters and then look at y'all your is
hateful is ignorant as can be please
answer your phone so I can tell you how
stupid you are we can debate I will be
respectful answer your phone what is it
wrongly uh answer when it's from an area
code that's Democrat majority No
what the [ __ ] are you lazy and only
answer two or three times a day we you
don't don't nothing but hate monger in
lie on Facebook and it's pathetic the
answer your phone so we can talk and cut
uh wait you come to a conclusion on
whether or not your hate mongering or
not yeah okay so the by the end it's
very clear this person is angry with me
no we I don't sit around answering the
phone two to three times a day
we take phone calls once sometimes twice
a week and I would love it if you called
in to talk to me we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about a
Harvard Law Professor suing the New York
Times over that guy who supposedly
committed suicide but a lot of people
are skeptical about that there's also a
conservative
group that is really mad at Burger King
for a particular word in one of their
ads and voters in California could
decide whether California cities will be
punished for not reducing homelessness
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member instantly by
signing up at join pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will speak to you
then